here was reaction 2024 presidential
candidate also a former governor and
former un Ambassador um I know
Ambassador you spent time at the UN I
think America is wasting billions every
year supporting that organization we're
wasting money on the WF we're wasting
money on the wh we are wasting money in
the Paris Accords China India are are
quote developing nations and we pay the
bulk of money for all of these
organizations am I right am I wrong
you're absolutely right it's why I
fought it the whole time it's why we got
out of the Human Rights Council it's why
I said we should get out of the World
Health Organization it's why the UN is
such a farce but you know what I'll tell
you Sean is I expected this from the UN
you expect all kinds of ridiculous
things at the UN I fought this battle
every day for two years what I don't
expect is to see what's happening in our
cities and what's happening on our
college campuses because these protests
that we're seeing are you telling me
that these professors that these college
students they are supporting a terrorist
organization that I've asked for a vote
at the United Nations and the majority
of the countries at the UN Sean agreed
that Hamas was a terrorist organization
yet we have Americans protesting saying
that they support an organization that
is a terrorist organization that killed
33 Americans that took almost 20 hostage
that said death to America and continues
to say death to America every day so do
these Americans want to see them destroy
America and if they do every one of them
is dangerous to our country every single
one of them because that's what Hamas
preaches is death to America so when
they get up there and they hold those
signs or they get upset on why people
won't hire them it's because companies
don't want to hire someone who wants to
destroy our country that's why I think
every name needs to be notified I mean
needs to be published every face needs
to be published and we need to call this
out for the hate that it is this is
Absolut unacceptable in America Governor
um Ambassador I don't know what you
prefer um should the United States in
time okay should the United States say
to the UN you're out get out no longer
are we going to be the home and no
longer are we going to fund it if you're
president if you got elected president
would you do that
what I would do is is dramatically
defund it you know I think that you have
to look at the fact why does the US stay
in why do Republican and Democrat
presidents stay in they stay in because
on the security Council we're one of
five vetos and if we don't veto these
bad things from happening these bad
things happen to us the number of things
that we stopped at the UN is the reason
you don't have to give them money you
did hear what was said this past week
and and and we do know that the uh that
the country of Iran is in November I
think they become the head of the world
Human Rights Commission really the
people that kill women that don't wear a
head covering the people that take gays
and lesbians and throw them off the tops
of buildings and murder them really
they're going to be the head of the
Human Rights Commission the why I why
not tell them to I got the us out of the
human
rights well I mean I think we could
leave but then Russia and China are in
charge that's the whole problem with all
that yes we could tell them to leave New
York and they'll go to London they'll go
to Paris they'll go somewhere else but
we don't want Russia and China to be in
charge but look but look at what Biden
did Biden allowed for a Visa for the
Iranian foreign minister to come to the
UN and speak on the world stage in
America a speech that threatened America
what sense does that make you should
never allow a terrorist on our soil when
they are threatening us it's those
things we need to fix
defund the the UN as much as possible
get out of the human rights commissional
get out of the Paris climate agreement
but don't let these people come to our
soor and threat in America should should
NATO remove turkey I believe NATO should
remove turkey erdogan has become nothing
but a more radical as every year has
passed and they' have been a useless
partner I believe they should be kicked
out of NATO what do you think turkey
continues to show why they are not a
true partner turkey continues to show
why they don't belong in NATO this is
just one more example of that I feel
like NATO has tried to make turkey work
turkeyy is not working and as
anti-semitic as they are right now no
they don't need to be in NATO well said
all right thank you Governor appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else